台湾股市知名的散户纪人节
今天为了版税捐赠的活动首度露面
并且分享自己的投资心法
他表示股市研究是需要从上到下
有理到外
例如最近很热门的议题
美国总统候选人川普
若是要对台积电课征更多的关税的话
那么影响到的不只是一档股价的表现了
包括其他上中下游概念股
也都是会受到波及的
因此就提醒
投资最重要的是设置停损点
如果进场的理由消失
就要及时止损
身高190公分
笑容腼腆的介绍自己
他是台湾投资人最好奇的
一级散户巨人节
看起来还不太熟悉面对镜头
不过很多人应该对他的名字不陌生
这次他为了版税捐赠活动
首度现身露面
回顾2021年光是他一个人
成交量就达到3000亿元
更在航运股热潮中一战成名
今年截至目前为止
也已经达到1500亿的成交量
他把股市交易员当成一份专职工作即使成家立业一天仍然投入10个小时研究股票從國內研究到海外川普可能要對台積電要多課增關稅
那因為這樣的關係
那對於台積電就會有影響
那台積電是加權指數中
成分最大的個股
那它有30幾%的關係
那如果它
而且尤其它的供應鏈很多
那它的上中下游
或是它的相關概念股都很多
那如果台积电行情不好的话
那其他个股的表现也不会很好
所以我的投资一定是会从上到下
这样去做分析
侃侃而谈分享自己的投资心法
同时巨人节也提到
虽然现在股市颇通剧烈
但对于喜欢当冲的他来说
价差变大反而更好操作
当然他也提醒
投资最重要的事情就是一定要涉陷
停损对我来说就是
进场的理由消失就停损
假设因为前阵子台积电上1000块
那1000块的时候大家会往上
例如看好其他的同族群的个股
包括设备也好
或是一些先进封装
这些跟台积电有关的个股
但是台积电前阵子破1000块了
那表示你的进场里有消失
那你就可以做停损动作
透过频繁交易累积经验值
在全球金融情势不稳定的情况下
操作策略也更加考验国海闯荡功力
记者黄友柔 陈玉志
台北采访报道